in 2007 there was almost one hate crime
reported every hour of every day in the
u.s. today the number reported is much
lower even though we know that hate
crime still happened regularly so why
did the numbers drop because the system
is broken
Chapel Hill Charleston and now Tulsa in
each of these cases the phrase hate
crime has been thrown around the FBI
defines a hate crime as motivated in
whole or in part by an offender's bias
against a race religion disability
sexual orientation ethnicity gender or
gender identity that should be easy
enough to prove right wrong courts are
increasingly requiring prosecutors to
show that hate was the sole motivating
factor behind a crime and not just a
substantial motivating factor On
February 10th 2015 the avocado siravo's
Aloha and Rosa Novosel ha were murdered
by their neighbor craig hicks
execution-style in their own home in
Chapel Hill North Carolina state
authorities claim these three young
American Muslims were shot and killed
over a parking dispute but to the
victims families it was clearly a hate
crime
Craig Hicks will likely not face any
hate crime charges because a court would
find that he was motivated by multiple
factors so why is it so important for
perpetrators to be charged with hate
crimes hate crimes our message crimes
they're meant to intimidate and inflame
and often do in some cases judges
prescribe very specific sentences in the
case of hate crimes in 2013 Abraham
Lincoln and Pinkus braver attacked Taj
Patterson as he was walking down a
Brooklyn Street the men screamed
anti-gay slurs before stomping and
kicking Patterson a judge sentenced the
two men to community service in a
culturally diverse neighborhood when
somebody attacks an individual because
of a protected category they're
attacking an entire community a hate
crime charge shows that community that
the government has their back there are
actually five states with no hate crime
laws on the books so what happens then
well the feds step in in June of 2015
twenty-one year-old Dylann roof walked
into a historically black church in
Charleston South Carolina and gunned
down nine worshippers he even said he
was there to shoot black people South
Carolina charged him with nine counts of
murder but the state has no hate crime
legislation so the DOJ took over and
their investigation led to 33 additional
federal hate crime counts he pled not
guilty to all of them and the case is
still pending and some states with laws
aren't even reporting these types of
crimes five states reported less than 10
hate crimes in 2014 Mississippi reported
one Wyoming reported zero our hate crime
reporting system is broken because it
relies on voluntary reporting by local
Police Department for us to have a
reliable system local law enforcement
must be required to report hate crimes
not just be asked we know that
Islamophobia isn't dying down in the US
and we know that racial tensions are
high so given the current climate isn't
it time we change this broken system